hallo mein Name ist Luca meine lieben
Freunde würdet ihr eher
älter sein oder jünger sein ich bin
mittlerweile 27 Jahre alt und bin ganz
ehrlich ich wäre eher ein Stückchen
jünger
[Musik]
66% sagen dass wir sind in der Mehrheit
würdest du eher von einem Elefanten auf
den Fuß getreten werden oder von einem
Löwen in den Fuß gebissen werden ich
glaube es ist beides nicht so entspannt
ich glaube allerdings dass schon Elefant
wenn er drauf tritt noch mal für
ordentlich mehr krabbumm sorgen kann von
der entscheide ich mich für den Löwen
das ist kompletter Schwachsinn würden
wir eher ohne Musik oder ohne Fernsehen
Leben ich weiß halt nicht ob sich
Fernsehen jetzt nur auf die Benutzung
eines Fernsehers bezieht oder das
Anschauen vom TV Sendern so oder so
würde ich mich trotzdem glaube ich
lieber für die Musik entscheiden und
damit sind wir auch definitiv in der
Mehrheit fernsehen kann mir gern
gestohlen bleiben würden wir eher
versuchen uns mit einem Gorilla oder
einem Bären anzufreuenten boah ich
glaube wir würden mit einem Gorilla
besser klarkommen weil wir Menschen ja
auch vom Affen abstammen deswegen
ersteres ja
wir sind wieder auf einem guten Weg
boah das sind schwierige Fragen eher 50%
gut in allem sein oder 100% gut in einer
Sache boah ich würde glaube ich doch ich
bin mir relativ sicher ich werde lieber
in allen Sachen 50%
das wäre schon krass wenn man so
so semi gut Fußball semikot Tennis man
kann so sehen wie gut jede Sprache
sprechen man kann alles so ein bisschen
das wäre schon krass alle unter euch die
mich und meine Ansichten sehr gut kennen
wissen direkt wofür ich mich hier
entscheiden würde und zwar steht uns
gegenüber der auch schon wahrscheinlich
gelesen beenden wieder eine Dusche haben
wollen die uns sieben Tage lang sauber
hält also wie du schon einmal und müssen
danach 7 Tage gar nicht mehr duschen
oder lieber ein Bett haben wollen was
uns eine völlige Nacht Ruhe in einer
Stunde ermöglicht
hundertprozentig das untere wir sind in
der Mehrheit aber nicht so doll wie ich
mir das vorgestellt habe und ich bin
ganz ehrlich ich kann jetzt nicht
verstehen wir Menschen schlafen wenn wir
das Beste aus unserem Schlaf und unsere
Erholung rausholen wollen acht Stunden
am Tag das ist ein Drittel weil ein Tag
ja 24 Stunden hat das heißt im
Umkehrschluss schlafen wir Menschen 33%
unseres Lebens
ein Drittel unseres Lebens verbringen
wir damit es nicht zu leben deswegen
wenn ich eine Superkraft besitzen könnte
wäre es dass ich nicht schlafen muss
würdest du eher überall kostenlos reisen
können oder überall umsonst essen können
boah ich glaube und da muss ich einfach
an diese Bedürfnispyramide denken ich
würde mich ganz gleich wie die
Grundbedürfnisse als immer als
allererstes entscheiden und die
Grundbedürfnisse sind eben essen trinken
schlafen von daher wir können ohne
Reisen überleben aber wir können nicht
ohne Essen überleben und wenn ich mein
Leben lang weiß ich kriege Essen
kostenlos entscheide ich mich dafür
ich
ich glaube ich denkt zu kompliziert
hätte ich lieber das Rad erfunden oder
das Internet ich glaube ich bin relativ
schnell diesmal ich nehme das Internet
sind wir ganz klar mit in der Mehrheit
wenn ich allerdings mit meinem jetzigen
Wissensstand das Internet hätte erfinden
können hätte ich safe gesagt für egal
was im Internet gemacht wird bekomme ich
einen Cent
ich wäre die reichste Person auf der
ganzen Welt würdest du eher der
Präsident oder ein Pokémon Trainer sein
ich bin ganz ehrlich ich strebe
überhaupt nicht nach macht dieses ganze
mit Präsident werden das ist in Amerika
ja so ein Riesending jeder will der
Präsident sein macht haben keine Ahnung
weil ich will das gar nicht je mehr
Leute dich dann kennen und wissen was du
machst hast die wollen was davon abhaben
und die wollen dir was Böses und so
deswegen hundertprozentig Pokémon
Trainer
lieber habe ich hier so ein Pikachu
neben mir sitzen was den ganzen Tag mit
mir chillt oder dass ich auf dem Glurak
auf die Malediven fliegt als dass ich da
so einen Tag lang leiten muss würdest du
eher einen kleinen Jungen oder ein
kleines Mädchen bekommen boah wenn ich
jetzt schon ein Kind hätte und das wäre
ein Junge dann würde ich mich definitiv
für das Mädchen entscheiden da ich noch
keine Kinder habe nämlich definitiv den
Jungen
ich glaube einfach wirklich dass die
meisten die diese App spielen Typen sind
weil Jungs einfach die sind total dumm
unser Geschlecht ist er Bär oder Gorilla
voll cool ich liebe diese würdest du
eher Videos die sind nicht bezahlt von
dieser App aber es ist einfach so schön
weil ich liebe das so viele so viel oder
so fragen darf zu denken und zu faseln
einfach würdest du eher schlechten Atem
haben oder stinkende Füße boah
ich hätte lieber stinkende Fürze wenn
ich mich entscheiden müsste zwischen
aber warum wenn ich mich entscheiden
müsste zwischen ich putze mir die Zähne
und zack eine Sekunde später habe ich
schon wieder einen stinkenden Mundgeruch
oder ich war schon meine Füße und zack
eine Sekunde später fangen sie wieder an
zu stinken nehme ich definitiv die Füße
bin ganz kleiner Mehrheit die Füße kann
man ja verdecken mit Socken mit Schuhen
aber was soll ich machen zwei Maske
rumlaufen oder was würdest du eher Augen
mit automatischer Videoaufnahme haben
boah richtig Black Mirror oder Ohren mit
automatischer Audioaufnahme okay Video
ist für mich halt Audio ein Video
zusammen das müssen wir hier glaube ich
ein bisschen differenzieren wenn man
wirklich davon ausgeht dass man entweder
nur Videos sehen kann oder nur Sachen
hören kann würde ich als allererstes und
ich glaube das da sind wir uns alle
einig und ich kann jetzt auch
draufklicken wir sind definitiv in der
Mehrheit die Augen nehmen
70%, aber
Audio ist das allererste was man
vergisst wenn eine Person stimmt das
allererste was du vergisst ist die
Stimme
deswegen
es sind so crazy philosophische Fragen
würdest du eher deinen Arm brechen oder
dein Bein brechen boah im besten Falle
natürlich gar nichts aber wenn ich mich
entscheiden müsste zwischen einem
Armbruch und einem Beinbruch würde ich
glaube ich den linken Arm nehmen weil
ich bin Rechtshänder deswegen den Arm
wenn man dumm denkt dann schafft man das
würdest du eher deine Mutter retten oder
dich selbst retten boah
ich ich glaube wenn ich auf deine Mutter
retten klicke sind wir safe in der
Mehrheit
ziemlich eindeutig oh das ist so eine
schwierige Frage weil ich wüsste dass
meine Mutter es mir niemals verzeihen
würde wenn ich meine Mutter retten würde
wenn ich selber Vater bin und mein Kind
hat die Wahl sich selbst zu retten oder
mich zu retten würde ich auch sagen hey
du hast dein Leben noch vor dir rette
dich
ich glaube ich nehme das alles ein
Ticken zu Ernst von daher würde ich
sagen beende ich das heutige Video mit
einer allerletzte Frage
würdest du
eher wissen wollen wann die Welt endet
oder
wie die Welt endet schreibt es mal unten
in die Kommentare ich bin gespannt was
ihr sagt und damit verabschiede ich mich
ins Wochenende meine Damen und Herren da
ja allerdings wahrscheinlich glaube ich
alle Ferien habt ist für euch gerade
aktuell jeder Tag Wochenende tschüss
[Musik]